so there's a guy who called into c-span
after the first deranged and depraved
evening of the republican national
convention
and the guy called in and said said he's
a lifelong democrat
but the first night of the republican
convention has convinced him to switch
his vote
and vote for donald trump now i'm going
to play the call for you in a moment
but what i want to raise ahead of time
is
in reaction to what i'm about to play
for you there's a lot of people who are
debating
is the guy for real or is he a troll is
this for real or is the guy
faking and he's really a trump guy who
just called c-span and said
that he's a lifelong democrat i have
some thoughts about that
but i'm actually going to make the case
that it doesn't matter and i'll explain
why but first let's take a look at the
video
rick in lorraine ohio democrat hi rick
tonight i'm a lifelong democrat i'm from
la reyno ohio which is a democrat city
in ohio
and i just want to say after watching
the convention tonight
on tv on c-span here i am definitely
changing my vote to republican
and i'll tell you what they just put the
democratic party they started republican
party to shame
i'm going to follow the republican party
now but why
what what what was it that convinced you
about tonight
it was the heartfelt way they came
across to the american people
and i was really touched by the number
of times they used the word
god they put god into everything
and the people on the democratic side on
their convention act like they were
pushing god right out of it
and that had a lot to do with changing
my mind
now rick did you say you were a union
member
no sir i'm from uh lorraine ohio
and we are a democratic town here and
have been for 50 years
that's it thank you so much so
in terms of whether this is for real or
where this is whether this is really a
trump guy who's lying that he's a
lifelong democrat
the guy said that he's calling from
a democrat city in ohio
i've never met a lifelong democrat who
calls
cities democrat cities that's how the
right talks
that's literally a term out of trump's
playbook
from the last two or three years so i
think that there's certainly reason
to doubt whether this guy is sincerely a
lifelong democrat
who was convinced to switch and vote for
trump from night one of the dnc
from the rnc rather but it doesn't
matter
okay this is sort of like looking at
retail versus wholesale
the question isn't whether this one guy
was really convinced to vote for trump
because of the rnc
someone in a country of 331 million
people with 120 to 135 million expected
to vote
someone i'm sure is going to be
convinced to vote trump
who was previously thinking they were
going to go vote biden by the rnc
the point is the big picture first it's
the big picture of conventions if
history is an indicator conventions
don't really do much for either
candidate
typically what you see is one candidate
has a convention and they get a little
bump
and then the other candidate has a
convention and they get a little bump
and then it fades
and by october nobody remembers it and
we've moved on to other things
the right has tried to make the case
that there is a massive movement of
democrats abandoning the democratic
party
and jumping ship to vote for donald
trump it's not backed up by the data
that we have
there's no doubt that there are
disaffected democrats who don't like the
fact that joe biden is a candidate some
of them are going to stay home some of
them are going to vote for donald trump
likewise there are people who voted
trump in 2016 who are going to vote for
biden
there is no evidence right now that
there are
large numbers of democrats defecting to
the republican party
or planning to vote for donald trump the
one caller
is not really newsworthy but there is
the more interesting and deeper question
about the bigger picture here which is
are people switching parties
what we know is that most 2016 trump
voters are going to vote for trump again
what we know is that most 2016 hillary
voters are going to vote for biden
what we know is that independents are
leaning towards joe biden
and ultimately this is going to come
down to
who votes in which states and how much
of the vote can donald trump suppress
so maybe it's true that this particular
guy
was a lifelong democrat and he was
convinced after a life of voting for
democrats to vote for donald trump
because of kimberly guilfoyle screaming
on monday night at the republican
national convention
or as he says because the republican
convention kept mentioning god
the truth of course is that in reality
joe biden is more religious than donald
trump it's not something
i care about but for people who want a
religious candidate
there's no question that donald trump's
religiosity is completely fabricated and
fake
as something to appeal to evangelical
voters with trump as a politician
whereas joe biden actually seems to be a
moderate moderately devout catholic
i don't care about that but if you're
looking for the religious candidate it's
not donald trump it's joe biden
uh but sure the caller might be making
it up as well
it doesn't matter if we all go out and
vote period
and uh that is ultimately going to be
the one test it's not
did this guy switch in ohio by the way
ohio
not looking as good for joe biden as it
did before or i guess better said
looking better for donald trump recently
than it did before uh what matters is if
we all go out and vote and the large
numbers and so i wouldn't be lulled into
a false debate about whether it's
possible that the rnc
really shifted a democrat into voting
for trump i'm sure
some democrats did get convinced to vote
trump from the rnc
and some republicans were convinced to
vote for joe biden from the dnc
we're a country of 331 million the big
picture is what matters
let's not lose sight of that and the big
picture is trump trump's going to try to
win by suppressing the vote
trump's going to try to win by rigging
the election that's the big picture
not whether this guy is a troll if
you've been watching the show you've
probably heard me talk about how much
i love my helix mattress well i was
really excited to hear that helix has
launched a new company called
all form which makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs
with the same level of quality and
comfort
that i expect from these guys and all
form is one of our sponsors today
they're giving you twenty percent off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put in my living room at home
it's now
my favorite piece of furniture in the
house
it took me just minutes to set it up
it's solidly built it's
huge it's roomy it has a modern
minimalist design which i love but it's
also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality it has become the
focal point of my living room
their prices are very reasonable and
when you get a new sofa or chair
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to
keep it and the best part is everything
comes
with a lifetime warranty stop buying
poorly made furniture
go to customize your own all form sofa
or chair right now and get
20 percent off your entire order when
you get there
by going to all form dot com slash
pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video